look
[Music]
hello how are you I am salt and jaramillo with
the most outstanding headlines for
today Monday November 23 the governor
of solá announced new restrictions
due to the increase in cases due to covenant
without the pause order at the state level will
begin on Tuesday from  from 12 1
m and will last a period of three weeks
now the limited capacity will be 25
% instead of 50 in places considered
high risk such as restaurants and
gyms also public meetings
will be no more than 50 people
private ones no more than 10  If the situation
worsens, the governor warned that he will be
stricter with the measures.
Yesterday, snowfall registered more than 2,100 cases and
6 deaths, that is the entire sum of almost
134,000 cases since the pandemic began.
The number of people hospitalized is
the highest, also due to the
massive contagion in upstate
another pharmacist says his
coronavirus vaccine experiment is a success
Astrazeneca says his dose t  has a
positive effect of 70 percent
depending on the dose
this is the third expert to reveal
details about the effectiveness of a
possible vaccine a difference between it
and fire is that it can be stored in
a normal refrigerator while
facer must be below  of
freezing temperatures
and now we move on with the weather forecast
we will have a sunny sky with
temperatures barely reaching 70
degrees however we will be rolling in the
60s for the rest of the week have
a nice day I am sal y jaramillo and
this was your informative brief  from news
now in Spanish
[Music]